hi leute ich habe heute historische
movie nahezu dating kriegen wir hinten
ja schon sehen könnt und das macht
natürlich nicht alleine sondern mit zwei
wunderbaren menschen und dass wir alle
viel so erlebt haben das könnt ihr jetzt
sehen wo mutter und ich lassen uns
schalten
monogamie ist unrealistisch monogamie
ist von real ist doch mal ne wally ist
unrealistisch
damals habe ich das wort nicht
verstanden aber heute weiß ich genau was
er damit gemeint hat
bekam keinen hoch betrunken geht es
nicht sehr groß die jemals in einer frau
drin wo sie beerdigt war die kirche
heute etwa für ruhig direkt ans wetter
schock denn neuerdings etwa online du
musst keine angst vor der ehe haben nur
weil du das konzept nicht verstehst du
ziehst ihn so an damit keine andere mit
dem sex haben will das ist cool
leute was ich sagen wollte dass es
verdammt heiß heute 36 grad draußen in
berlin eine sache übrigens zum original
trailer erstes mal gegoogelt
ja ja ja hast du train wreck mobiler
trennwände googelt und da kriegst du die
krassesten fall fälle ich wollte ich ihn
privat team aus meinem kopf raus und so
weiter geht
so meint harry braun partner mein name
mit der nummer 74 verschiedene
abschnitte ich bin hier oben die leute
meinung wird zu checken ob die was drauf
hat und wenn sie was drauf haben können
sie was gewinnen ganz genau ein meet
greet so geht's mir bei libro bei der
social hub schüsse
so liebe freunde herzlich willkommen zur
24 social mobile bitte erstmal ein
riesenapplaus herzlich willkommen für
robert hofmann
es gibt zu wenig regisseurinnen es gibt
zu wenig große rollen für frauen die
wandeln sich dann zu wenig die figuren
oder frauen sind auf sex symbole dann
kommt ein solcher film daher der
irgendwie ein statement hat ganz ehrlich
warum muss ich kann machen was ich will
dann nämlich kann aussehen wie ich kann
trotzdem spaß haben und das ist mal ein
ganz klares statement was du so selten
so viele hassten das bin ich so cool so
meili sind elisa und war dass er einmal
von mal bade und oder löschen
herzlich willkommen riester preis
ich habe mir sogar ein anderer spruch
ausgedacht für heute abend ok pass auf
war ich jetzt auch seine der den queen
bin ist dein gesicht in tochter gefallen
weil du so süß aussiehst oder ja danke
ich fange an im mit dem regisseur der
bereits auch schon mit der 40-jährigen
jungfrau oder auch beim ersten mal für
furore gesorgt hat bei den damen und
herren eine riesa post ab meine damen
und herren an den riesen applaus zu
vanessa br
und sie wird auch begleitet von auch
ihren kollegen der leider nicht mit
dabei ist auch noch eine riesen
kramer
und die ärzte gesagt viel spaß mit der
dating bevor er nicht verurteilt
ich versuche mir geht es prima meine
freunde sind toll
eine wohnung ist geil und ich haben
hammer job beim männermagazin amy klasse
pitch anal kostet doch ihren saft
richtig gut danke sie erst niki du wirst
recherchieren ob knoblauch sich auf den
geschmack von sperma auswirkt wie soll
ich das bitte danke herausfinden ihr
inspiriert mich ich habe einen auftrag
für dich du schreibst den artikel über
diesen sport doktor
wollen wir was trinken gehen
was habe ich getan ich habe jetzt nicht
bei dem arzt über nacht ein freund wurde
also in china
das heißt geschlechtsverkehr ruft an
hier hatte doch gerade erst hier ist es
ganz bestimmt hast du dich mit aussicht
angerufen hat er sagt dass es schwer
fällt mich an ich hoffe an weil ich die
letzten acht super fand vielleicht
können wir das ja bald mal wiederholen
ich hatte die polizei verständigen ich
fand den humor sehr gut getroffen
eigentlich ja ziemlich witzig ich hab
echt selten im kino so gute stimmung mit
bekommen das war richtig cool dann hatte
ich überraschenderweise doch gewonnen
und meine freundin wollte dann doch
nicht mitkommen da musste ich meinen
kumpel dahinten mitnehmen und wird acht
jahre lassen was mal auf uns zukommen
aber wir sind teilweise aus dem lachen
ganzen herausgekommen
also ich finde den film cool ich bin
doch die arten gesetzt haben cool ich
habe mehr gelacht als ich erwartet habe
ich fand den film von vorne bis hinten
perfekt er hatte so viele lacher drin
dass ich ich bin also das habe ich ganz
selten dass ich wirklich nach vorne
fallen lasse und dann richtig gemacht
und trainer hatte ich irgendwie zehnmal
und ja ich fand den super hier leser
bist du aus so kaputt wie ich
geschmolzen zugleich eine wand im wasser
warum ist also wir sagen jetzt ist es
war ein wunderschöner abend
danke dass so viele von euch gekommen
sein und fotos gemacht haben und dass
ich mit euch quatschen konnte und wir
schmelzen jetzt dahin tschüss